oh man is that a prism duro sport you've
seen one of these yeah they're like an
iPod only they're better cuz they're
chunkier and more solid Roy gave it to
me for Christmas I'm trying to figure
out how to put songs on it oh no no no
don't go there I know this Russian
website you can download songs for two
cents apiece really yeah I'll write down
the address for you only the only thing
is is that all the songs are in Russian
kidding why would the AL beat okay see
you later Pan
yeah these covers are totally
indestructible really yeah throw it I
promise it won't break check it oh no
it's broken
what no it's fine I told you it wouldn't
break you could throw it all day long
that is so cool
thanks Dwight so I guess Pam and Dwight
are friends now
oh god no Dwight isn't my friend oh my
god Dwight it's kind of my friend Malika
let's just get the drink what are you
doing Oh Vietnam sounds stop stop stop
stop
tired wake up
just keep them moist no I was like
chicken soup I know I have to go to the
hospital
no are we going I just want to say
goodbye okay I'll be back
yes I know but it's gonna be different
why just hard to explain if I write my
suggestions down to I'm not writing
worse hunt I don't even know that means
it's in the name okay
so far our ideal party consists of beer
fights to the death cupcakes
blood pudding blood touch football
mating charades
and yes or something you're right I
forget horse hunting it's stupid is
there a birthday that you remember that
you loved here's one it was dark warm
wet a sudden burst of light an intense
pressure like I'd never felt before
father dressed in white pulls me forward
mother
bites the cord they stop forever stop
that story that's disgusting and it
doesn't count so give me another one
schrutes don't celebrate birthdays idiot
it started as a depression-era
practicality and then moved on to an
awesome tradition that i look forward to
every year
are you kidding I'm not done yet wait
this fits in the palm of my hand you
haven't blown them up enough why have
you chosen brown and gray balloons they
match the carpet what is that it is your
birthday Pierce Damon a fact not even an
exclamation point this is more
professional it's not like she
discovered a cure for cancer I can't
believe I've added this Lex are you
trying to hurt my feelings because if so
you are succeeding Oh judgement is nigh
but that banished Nicholas ah yes he is
finally nigh I am 9 every year my
grandfather would dress up his
Belsnickel at Christmas he was okay at
it I am great you know they say some
people were born to be bad while I was
born to be Belsnickel I traveled from
distant lands to discover how all the
boys and the girls have been behaving
this last year whoa too much strudel so
he's kind of like Santa except dirty and
worse no much better no one if you have
Santa the way they feel best Inga Wow
my favorite part of Christmas the
authority and the fear
yes exactly come on boy you're making
this up oh this is a real thing
Belsnickel is a crotchety fur-clad gift
giver related to other companions of
Saint Nicholas in the folklore of
southwestern Germany yes okay great
seriously you guys now you believe in
Dwight's traditions when something
Democrat looks it up on Wikipedia his
partner shabbath de Pete or black Peter
a slave boy often portrayed in colorful
pantaloons and blackface uh uh no Dwight
no no come on
we don't blindly stick to every outmoded
aspect of our traditions come on give it
the spirit of it you guys
you're gonna quiet that baby or do I
have to in a Schrute family well the
youngest child always raises the others
I've been raising children since I was a
baby it's a miracle she loves him I
don't know about love she loves me
oh my cartoon it's nice and things come
up I gotta go no she'll wake up now I
have something to do I know what you
have to do please stay with CeCe
twice I've always considered us to be
very good friends great friends remember
your concussion I do but you're married
now where's Tiffany well I think enemy's
a strong word cuz I think we have a
really charming back-and-forth and a
suit
I will require beer and pizza to think
this over from Jim Wow I think that's do
it
what kind of beats would you like
surprise me
no pepperoni wow what is wrong with this
thing looks terrible do you want me to
ask the night cleaning crew if they
stopped watering it yeah oh you know
what ask them about the toys on my desk
too
they always used to arrange the toys on
my desk in a a very pleasing way used to
brighten my morning oh that wasn't the
night crew that was Dwight really that
was very nice of them we need more
attitude like that around this office
happy Valentine's Day it's me
I'm the bobble head yes ah I wanted to
thank you for helping me when you held
the title of secret assistant to the
regional manager you served the office
with great dignity
you've reached the voicemail of Dwight
Kurt Schrute please leave
[Music]
I have no feeling and my fingers or
penis but I think it was worth it feels
good boy tell me where it hurts right
right there oh yeah you've got a knot in
your crest this remedy has been passed
down in my family for generations and it
always works
my grandfather was told that diamond
dancer would never race again they were
wrong he came in 9th in the Apple Creek
Derby and as jerkey came in third the
following year a majestic beast so fast
so tender what the rat we're so scary
no please I find the rattle soothing
puts me to sleep
I think Bob's gonna cheat on me with his
new secretary not so funny I say it out
loud it it's so silly
[Music]
wanna dance why
ordinarily I would say no but you need
to move to reduce lactic acid buildup
also the song is fantastic
if I steal my wife you can't steal what
is legally your property
you